the uncovering of a painful past for Generations
a small Church Cemetery was buried in the brush
until parishioners volunteers and descendants of
those laid to rest there began a massive cleanup
effort as cbs's Scott McFarland reports they've
brought new light on a dark part of American
history behind the Sacred Heart Chapel in
Bowie Maryland a long forgotten Cemetery in
the 1700s the Jesuits founded a church here and
a plantation that kept people enslaved including
Kevin Porter's ancestors this is where they
live this is where they came to commune after
laboring all day as the Catholic church
acknowledges this horror of its past its
archdiocese in Washington recently brought in an
anthropologist to map and document possible grave
sites in an overgrown area next to an existing
Cemetery so every stone you know firmly fixed in
you're going to Mark with a pink flag as
volunteers including church members and some
7th and eighth generation descendants swept
raked and blew away years of debris they saw
centuries-old Stones grave markers and indications
of burials oftentimes people you know people
who were enslaved people who are people of color
could not afford to buy stones and so they marked
grapes with fieldstones is it possible dozens of
people were buried here it's likely that hundreds
of peoples are buried here with this clearing
process complete the church will spend months now
grappling with how to properly Mark and preserve
what's really a tragic piece of the church's
history The Church says a committee of descendants
experts and church leaders will eventually
determine how to Mark and honor the cemetery it's
part of the history and it has been talked about
but needs to be talked about more other
organizations and governments are seeking to
do the same one of them the state of Maryland has
considered legislation ordering a formal review
of burial places through the state to determine
where money is needed to find and preserve burial
grounds of historic significance to the enslaved
African-American experience this is where our
ancestors are buried or Kevin Porter hopes to see
a memorial on the site one day it's important that
we uncover them honor them this site is important
to our family it's important to American history I
think we need Memorial is telling those stories
he hopes there is learning and reflection in
the future from this piece of history for CBS
Saturday morning Scott McFarland Bowie Maryland
the Committees is going to be their lives mattered
and they deserve being remembered and so still do
yeah so well said there by Kevin have this
moment to learn from that and let's remember
them and honor them can't fully write these
wrongs but you can do something today thank you